you're going to tell us everything you
know
i'm not telling you a mother
you can electrocute him all day it'll
only make him angrier
i on the other hand will tell you
everything really
michael bryce was trying to put his past
behind him you need to forget
bodyguarding repeat after me
no bodyguarding no
then he got pulled back in let's go
jesus to protect
this homicidal nut bags wife what is he
doing here
i said get anyone but michael rice
i believe it's pronounced thank you
in four days all of you loved was burned
they're planning a full-scale cyber
attack do not screw this up
oh we are definitely gonna screw this up
i promised my therapist no bodyguarding
let's not do that guys let's just focus
i got it no it's fine you guys just you
guys have had him
maybe feather the break a bit i need you
to protect us
we're trying to have a baby
we gotta have mercy on ourselves now
repeat after me i'm unlicensed i'm
unlicensed that's terrible louder i'm
unlicensed
[Applause]
with us that also came out wrong now
let's go do what we do
and blow some things up
i would make a great mother don't you i
think you're good mother
thank you it must be your powerful
asexuality that makes you such a good
listener
we just acknowledge that not only are we
safe this really feels like a newbie